[Music]
hello and welcome to our session on
building your data career with Google
Cloud credentials
I'm Emma Freeman and I manage our
portfolio of learning and training
content for data analytics and machine
learning at Google Cloud
in today's session we'll be talking with
you about the Google Cloud
certifications specifically those that
deal with data roles which includes the
professional Cloud database engineer the
professional machine learning engineer
and the professional data engineer
certifications
you'll hear about what attributes
generally characterize the best
candidates reasons to pursue the path
yourself plus the concepts you can
expect on these exams and all of the
best resources you can use to prepare
first we'll discuss how Google Cloud
certifications can help you level up
your expertise and your career
as you may know datawork has been moving
rapidly to the cloud and will continue
to do so
As you move forward in your data career
it's critical that you build nurture and
validate your Cloud skills to evolve
with these rapid changes in the
technology and business landscape
this means keeping your skills sharp
staying ahead of the curve standing out
from other skilled professionals
developing and validating your skills
all while balancing your professional
and your academic responsibilities
businesses look for candidates with
certifications recruiters say that
they're interested in hiring certified
professionals who have proven
competencies in the cloud
recruiters seek out candidates who have
certifications as these are an easy way
and to recognize talented and qualified
people
many hiring managers value the hands-on
experience and certifications over a
University degree when they're
evaluating candidates
these are some statistics that came out
of the Google Cloud certification impact
report in 2020.
this report found that the vast majority
of Google Cloud certified individuals
feel more confident in their
professional future can prove Cloud
skill competency to recruiters feel that
their resume is more attractive and feel
more confident in their own cloud skills
these are some great reasons why you
should pursue Google Cloud
certifications
the first certification we'll discuss is
the new Google Cloud professional
database engineer certification
for this one I'll hand it over to sway
thanks Emma you know we launched the new
Cloud database engineer certification
last July and since then we've seen just
an amazing amount of interest in this
certification so I'm really happy to get
the opportunity to share more
now first off you may be wondering why
we decided to release this new
certification
the first reason is database
modernization we've seen growing
interest from customers in migrating
from expensive Legacy database Solutions
onto open source databases like MySQL
and postgres
we've also seen interest in customers
wanting to migrate to our transformative
databases such as Cloud spanner and
bigtable
second the cloud database industry is
rapidly evolving in fact the market for
cloud databases is projected to reach
over 68 billion dollars by 2026.
because of all this traditional data
management roles have evolved and now
call for a different skill set than the
traditional database administrator
they've evolved to include cloud data
management expertise guiding developers
on picking the right database
architecture and services for particular
use cases or applications
and we're also seeing that these Cloud
database Engineers need to be familiar
with like for like databases between
on-premises Technologies and cloud
services
so these Engineers they know how to
select the right managed offering based
on trade-offs between workload and
access requirements data models latency
availability and scalability but also
battling this balancing this with the
lowest cost offering
and when performance problems arise they
help application developers pinpoint and
resolve performance bottlenecks at the
database layer or helping identify the
cause in the underlying Cloud
infrastructure
now while organizations are increasingly
recognizing the benefits of bringing
Legacy database platforms to Google
Cloud managed Services they're
challenged to find
the right people with these high demand
skills
the Google Cloud database engineer
certification is designed to address
these challenges
a professional Cloud database engineer
designs creates manages and
troubleshoots Google Cloud databases
used by applications to store and
retrieve data
they should be comfortable translating
business and Technical requirements into
scalable and cost-effective database
Solutions
now this exam covers all of the Google
Cloud database products in depth the
differences between them when to use
which one for different use cases as
well as the trade-offs
optimizing queries and improving
performance failover Disaster Recovery
High availability
migrating from on-premises databases to
Cloud databases and the tools that could
be used as well as best practices
you know it's kind of helpful to think
about the framework that database
Engineers think of on a regular basis
as they walk through use cases including
how to solve for these use cases using
Google Cloud databases
for example if you're running your
databases on premises and you want to
migrate to Google Cloud what are some
questions that you would want to work
through
well you might want to ask what are the
real steps and techniques that you would
apply to move data from point A to point
B
how do you select the best Google Cloud
database for your new application or
your existing application
what are the benefits and drawbacks of
each option
how do you translate business
requirements into database Solutions on
Google Cloud
so this question is really focused on
use cases what database engines make the
most sense whether you need a relational
database or a non-relational database so
you're kind of thinking about all of
these Concepts that are near and dear to
Your Heart High availability disaster
recovery scalability backup performance
Etc
not once running on Google Cloud well
then now you have to perform certain
tasks and now you have to think about
different concepts such as how do I
deploy a new database in the cloud how
do I deal with failovers scaling up and
now creating replicas connecting to the
database and handling identity and
access management
having said that what are the reasons
why you might want to get certified to
be a database engineer
well besides validating the skills that
we just mentioned it's going to
demonstrate your ability to lead
database migration efforts to manage
Cloud databases and guide organizational
decisions based on your company's use
cases
it also gives you an opportunity to
demonstrate your knowledge and
experience with Google Cloud databases
such as Cloud SQL Cloud spanner bigtable
alloy DB firestore and memory store
so who would be the right person to take
on this certification
well we would really recommend five
years of experience working with
databases with two of those years with
hands-on experience with Google Cloud
databases
and the reason for that is this exam was
created for those professionals working
with databases so they know all the
basic concepts they've done migrations
they've done deployment troubleshooting
they've done all of the activities that
a database administrator would do
plus they've had experience doing this
with Google Cloud databases
now you can
and round out your skills by going
through our recommended learning path as
you see here
this is our Learning Journey map and you
can use this to start preparing for the
exam
by doing this you're going to get
hands-on experience and practice with
Google Cloud database products and
solutions
now what we recommend is that you first
start by checking out the exam guide
take a look at that guide and then
identify areas where you might need to
enhance your skills or your knowledge
then you can learn and get hands-on
experience using this learning path
where it contains courses on Google
Cloud Core infrastructure Enterprise
database migration and we also have four
Hands-On skill batch quests about Google
Cloud SQL Cloud spanner and bigtable
and then there's links to additional
resources on the exam site like
documentation so you can round out your
knowledge and get the information that
you need to be successful during the
exam
make sure to keep on checking the exam
guide as you prepare
hopefully that gives you some good
information to start your journey on the
new Google Cloud database engineer
certification
with that I'm going to hand it back to
Emma to talk about the professional data
engineer certification
the engineer enables data-driven
decision making by collecting
transforming and serving data
the data engineer designs builds
maintains and troubleshoots data
processing systems with a particular
emphasis on the security reliability
fault tolerance scalability and
efficiency of these systems
these data pipelines and systems enable
data teams to gain insights and build
machine learning models to support
decision making
as well as automate and simplify key
business processes
for this certification we recommend that
you have at least three years of
Industry experience working with data
engineering including a year or more
designing and managing Solutions using
Google Cloud
the exam assesses your ability to design
data processing systems which includes
selecting data storage Technologies for
given use cases and considerations about
business requirements and various
technical trade-offs
it also assesses your ability to build
an operationalize data processing
systems including batch and streaming
pipelines distributed systems
architecture capacity planning and
migrating from on-prem to Cloud
Solutions
it also assesses your ability to use
managed Google Cloud database services
build Monitor and test pipelines for
data cleaning ingestion transformation
and integration
it also looks at your ability to
operationalize machine learning models
where you might work with pre-built ml
models and choose the appropriate model
training and serving infrastructure to
deliver data to those models
finally it assesses your ability to
ensure solution quality which includes
considerations about security and
compliance scalability efficiency
reliability and flexibility all while
ensuring that these systems meet current
and future stakeholder requirements
so why should you get certified as a
Google cloud data engineer
this certification is the number one top
paid certification globally according to
Global Knowledge market research
by following the recommended learning
path you'll complete more than 30
Hands-On data engineering labs in a
Google Cloud project environment to
practice building and deploying data
processing Solutions with Google Cloud
products
you'll also learn some of the most
valuable and in-demand Enterprise skills
in the market and prove yourself
indispensable to organizations who are
modernizing their data platforms and
looking to adopt machine learning
you'll also learn data engineering best
practices from Google Cloud
by getting this certification you'll
differentiate yourself for Career
Success by showing that you know how to
choose the right data storage and
processing Services identify the right
balance of trade-offs for different
types of data workloads and get practice
implementing production tested data
processing design patterns
to prepare for the exam we have a
recommended learning path that covers
foundational data Concepts and data
pipeline design patterns as well as key
data ingestion storage and
transformation processes all using
Google Cloud products
this learning path will give you
opportunities to do instructor-led or
on-demand courses as well as Hands-On
skill badges in order to get the
practice you need to ensure you're ready
to take the exam
and just like with the database engineer
certification we recommend that you
check the exam guide before you start
learning to understand where you're at
with your Readiness to take the
certification exam and finally make sure
to check the exam guide again when you
sign up to take the exam this will help
you be very well prepared to pass your
certification
now let's discuss the professional
machine learning engineer certification
a machine learning engineer designs
builds and productionizes machine
learning models in order to solve
business challenges using Google Cloud
Technologies and knowledge of proven ml
models and techniques
through an understanding of training
retraining deploying scheduling
monitoring and improving models an ml
engineer designs and creates scalable
solutions for Optimal Performance
additionally ml Engineers consider
responsible AI throughout the ml
development process and they collaborate
closely with other job roles to ensure
the long-term success of ml models
for this certification we also recommend
at least three years of Industry
experience in a data science or machine
learning engineer role including at
least a year where you're designing and
managing Solutions using Google Cloud
the exam covers your ability to frame ml
problems architect ml Solutions design
data preparation and processing systems
including batch and streaming data
automate and orchestrate ml pipelines
help develop ml models
and monitor optimize and maintain ml
Solutions
so why should you get certified as a
Google Cloud machine learning engineer
this certification is continuously
updated by Leading Google and Industry
subject matter experts in order to best
reflect the most up-to-date mle skill
set in the job market
getting this certification will give you
the opportunity to validate your
expertise in machine learning and Google
Cloud against a rigorous practical
Benchmark exam that's recognized across
the industry
just like with the other certifications
we have a recommended learning path
where you can get the Hands-On practice
as well as on demand or instructor-led
classroom experience to learn all about
ml Solutions on Google Cloud going from
Big Data and machine learning
fundamentals to how do you do machine
learning on Google cloud and moving into
more advanced topics like machine
learning with tensorflow ML Ops ml
pipelines for production and deploying
ml Solutions using vertex AI
and again we recommend you really check
out the exam guide and the sample
questions in order to assess your
Readiness to take the exam those
resources will get you the best prepared
you can be to pass your certification
to wrap things up we have some great
learning resources available for you to
continue your learning with Google Cloud
I recommend that you check out the links
on this slide to explore further
opportunities to continue learning with
us
thank you so much for joining us today
foreign